[Music]
let's try one of these so-called hover
chunks ooh it's not just chocolate is it
there marshmallow that's right harvested
from the malow marshes of Peru and
caramel but salted with the Bittersweet
tears of Russian
clown is that surely not Cherry Cherry
Picked by The Pick of the Cherry Pickers
from the Imperial Gardens in
Japan well Mr Wonka I've been in this
business a very long time and I can
safely say that of all the chocolate I
have ever tasted this is without doubt
the absolute 100% West wooo there we
have it ladies and gentlemen an
endorsement for mistress wait the the
worst we three are the fiercest of
Rivals and yet we agree on one thing a
good chocolate should be simple plain
uncomplicated whereas this with all its
bells and whistles well it's just weird
I'm going to hate what happens
next what's happening what's going on
that's the hoverfly broken out of its
cocoon it's slapping its wings like
Bila what hell you're up your rocker
Wonka who in their right mind wants a
chocolate that makes it Fly let's find
out shall we who's for
hover please thank you thank you very
much
one thank you madam enjoy your
[Music]
[Applause]
fight
[Music]
gotcha so you're the funny little man
who's been following me funny little man
how dare you I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size for an
OA Lumpa an OA what now in fact in Lumpa
land I am regarded as something of a
Whopper they call me lofty
sorry ladies and gentlemen greetings to
you all my name is Willie won you see
I'm something of a magician prepare to
be amazed tap
up inventor may I present Willy Wonka's
wild and wonderful wishy-washy WKA
Walker please don't make me say that
again and chocolate
Baker the best chocolate in the
world
o he's good too good and anyone can
afford them even the the poor
he doesn't like it when people say poor
send Wonka a message do not sell
chocolate in this town you're going to
get more than a bonk on the head I love
a bonk on the head what is with me
today you should stand up to those
Buddhists give them the old one
too I got an idea where do we start
making chocolate of
course run away every good thing in this
world started with a
dream so you hold on to
yours I guess it's time to change the
[Music]
world
I'm not in
prium good night sir I am going
flat
huh what is it nothing well it's
obviously something because you said huh
forget it very
well huh you did it again tell me what
it is or I shall poke you quite
viciously with a cocktail stick
[Music]
he